See.
Reality is gross.
It so is.
Hey, have you ever heard of the fourth wall?
No.
Oh, I have.
Don't just google it!
Oh, never mind.
Anyways, the fourth wall is this imaginary wall that the audience sees through.
What?
Like on a sitcom?
Yeah.
Exactly.
That's the world I want to live in.
That's where real happiness is.
Totally.
Wait.
What do you mean?
Think about it.
When you have an audience, everything's better.
Right?
Like everything that's dumb and boring, and ugly becomes like cool and part of your story.
Like this stinky bus, it would be way better if it was on TV.
Right?
You're totally right, Letty.
All these people would be like way better versions of themselves.
Exactly.
They'd be like the same, but way cooler.
Yeah.
And they have like real products that we actually want.
Right?
Totally.
The reason TV is so much better for us is 'cause it's packed with everything we want.
You're totally right, Letty.
Life would be like way better if it were TV.
I know.
Reality is bad for us.